that no not yet I was gonna say I was
gonna say we should Pace it this way
because let's compare leaks yes think
that's because like you got Media
Matters trying to destroy Tucker by
leaking all these Snippets and being the
coolest dude ever and then you have
Crowder panicking because he's just he's
a literal psycho whenever he's not on
camera it's the best I love I love these
leaks so Media Matters got some more
footage okay
I'm loving these as much as the Crowder
stuff for different reasons and by all
intents and purposes the only way Media
Matters could have gotten these leaks
was from a fox employee because the fox
employee has access to the live
satellite feed for those who don't know
Tucker does his show from from his own
studio and this has been this isn't new
this has been going on for years like if
you had a satellite back in the day you
could catch it tonight show them talking
during the break and all that stuff and
some of the best clips of early like raw
and stuff are like the satellite feed
production trucks right so it's kind of
like that I remember all the little
announcers talking [__] and stuff off
the air right that was great
um so
here's one of the leaks you ready bro
he's done he's canceled for leak number
one everyone in this company is thrilled
that you're doing this I've gotten more
calls from people about it oh that's
great whatever I got to say that's
Pierce Morgan he's talking to you by the
way came to um New York a couple of
weeks ago I couldn't believe how
welcoming and friendly everybody was it
was fantastic I loved it
yeah they they really mean it from the
owners on down yeah um it's cool it's
cool to see it I like that it's it's a
good you know people are nice in this
company I think they've always been nice
to agree with you I completely agree
everyone's been very very friendly and
very nice and I really appreciate it but
thank you so much for coming on it's uh
I bet that doesn't change of course is
this great to have you on my show I mean
I've been on yours enough times it's
great
I think it's totally cool
if we're going to talk about sex I'd
love to hit some of the fine points of
technique
good joke that's a good joke man come on
he was laughing but you know but it's
your show it's totally up to you we can
certainly talk about your sexual
technique especially after your tanning
testicles last week not mine oh they're
talking about the uh the one that Ron
Agnes was on the being a man thing that
he did their testicles speak in more
general terms but I've got something to
add
so wow what a [__] what a name they
are legitimately thinking this is my
theory got him my theory is when you get
to that level of Media Matters like
there's such a cult now and all the
highest ranking people in this cult that
get all the good juicy information
they're so out of touch with what reg
like they they look at this and go look
at him look he's goofing around she's
treating our studio like it's trash
we're the mainstream this is Legacy
Media pal and like they don't realize we
have no respect for any of this [__]
this is the kind of [__] to making
regular non-at-touch people go ah Tucker
is kind of fun like he seems like the
most fun guy there it seems kind of
funny now
there's a few merch and I had different
favorite ones this is my favorite one
and by the way just for the term
remember we were talking about the
satellite earlier when he mentioned the
bird what he's talking about is a
satellite team just so you know you get
the context here you go you wouldn't
okay I'm not you know what I'm not
qualified on that score I will say
I thought his girlfriend was kind of
yummy I thought his girlfriend was kind
of yummy which by the way
who cares we do that [__] all the time
we do this all the time
just kidding just kidding cases being
pulled off the bird
yeah the bird hey Media Matters for
America go [__] yourself oh my God oh my
God
did you not you haven't seen that that
one I heard the bird part of the show oh
my God so you're leaking stuff what they
both what's this so you're leaking stuff
that he recorded probably a year or two
ago
2021 so two years ago he knew you were
guys
and he's literally in your face [__]
with you and then you post it and you
think like oh yeah like look at Tucker B
no that's hilarious he made a joke and
immediately got [__] you media manage I
know you're recording me you're obsessed
with me
I I he he what are you gonna do Media
Matters are you gonna tweet out oh rent
free you know what media matter should
have done I ain't posting that [__] I
got my ass kicked dude
I'm posting that [__] I got my ass beat
yeah you know what I'm not qualified on
that score I will say I thought his
girlfriend was kind of yummy
just kidding just kidding cases being
pulled off the bird
yeah the bird hey Media Matters for
America go [__] yourself that's gonna be
a response gift of mine forever now by
the way the go [__] yourself
I also like the one of Tucker in that
interview when he's like [__] you I hate
you I hate you
for America go [__] yourself
that's the first thing I want to say
tonight second thing is totally kidding
I don't even know what his girlfriend
looks like and if I did I would not find
her yummy
hahaha
and you still have you posted it I don't
I don't get it man
it's really funny
I found her yummy well he [__] rules
holy [__] that's so good that is so
[__] good Jesus Christ he really is
just the most likable guy in media when
you please leak more of this
dude I'm telling you I'm telling you
Tucker rules and of course this is my
favorite this one this is mine this is
awesome I love this one this is his we
all do this of course we all the time
everybody I know that broadcast does
this move
well I feel great you know I can never I
can never assess my appearance I wait
for
my post-menopausal fans to weigh in
[Laughter]
he [__]
ing the best
that is literally something we would say
I guess more feel great you know I can
never I can never assess my appearance I
wait for
my post-menopausal fans to weigh in
my FB
what they want to control me from afar
okay I'm putting the leash on
you can
[Laughter]
I today's been so good everything I
don't even know I don't know anyone in
broadcasting that has not made this joke
in a studio at least once
oh my [__] things stinks the [__]
tank stinks
makes me so happy you can
[__] it we'll do it live
there's somebody shrieking in the
background laughing too like if you hit
play you can actually hear somebody
howling
you can
[__] it we'll do it live
you heard him I got you baby
yeah I'd hate working with that guy yeah
it seems like I can see why that woman I
can see why that super fun looking
Jewish woman is suing him so now let's
compare the leaks the Crowder leaks and
the Tucker leagues who came out looking
cool
I mean they're well you want to talk
about
oh [__] two very different people
why
please immediate matters I will
literally donate to you guys if you get
me more of these can you please give me
more of these because these are amazing
and you Universe Media Matters is
universally getting panned yeah of
course everyone even lefties are like
this is not really a Smoking Gun and
you're actually humanizing him and he's
even the ones that are like oh white
supremacists but you're humanizing them
with these clips we even said like one
of the top comments was a person was
like I'm a liberal and I do not like
Tucker but you just made me love him
like yeah why are you posting this yeah
it's like you're humanizing him yeah
something you see you're disgusted here
here's the thing Media Matters and the
people that run Media Matters see you
literally like
think humans are disgusting yeah that's
a good point and so humanizing things
makes you go oh and you're like well
let's make everybody see how gross and
human this person is see we're human
beings so when you humanize somebody it
has the opposite effect on our emotions
that it does on yours just a pro tip
it really it really is it's like an
alien like you know we talk about aliens
trying to understand like
anybody the three Clips we just saw
anybody regardless of your political
alignment will look at that and go
yeah I've been like that in my job you
know I get it you know yeah what do you
again The Smoking Gun if you really
wanted to kill Tucker was getting Tucker
doing what Crowder does like yeah being
a psychopath to a psychopath yeah if
they had Crowder level leaks on talker
boy it would be a different story we
might even be like wow what a [__]
[__] like but Tucker's not known for
treating people the way Crowder does
right but yeah if there was leaks like
him just [__] watch it and just be
but it's not it's him giggling and being
like [__] it we'll do it live I'm joking
around like who cares a famous Bill
O'Reilly thing that we've all watched a
thousand times now you know what I'm
gonna do from now on because the one
thing that's not it's not the one you
think every time I'm ranting I'm gonna
go and in case you're watching from the
bird from the bird [__] you Media
Matters
um